alors bonjour à la planète la planète
est là la planète et la tête à plusieurs
endroits aujourd'hui la planète et elle
est à quatre endroits différents
c'est les quatre points cardinaux on est
cerné de partout alors alors à
l'émission tam-tam canada cette semaine
nous avons notre dream team all c'est
maintenant en anglais on dit non
seulement il ya un marivaux cayla mais
il ya un vieux collègues de radio canada
international de la section anglaise et
demi pour la première fois dans cette
formule d'émission il a déjà participé
dans d'autres émissions françaises mais
là dans cette grande émission la plus
grande des émissions c'est sa première
fille mercy ses ventes et les bonnes il
faut le dire vous avez appris l'anglais
votre langue maternelle c'est pas
l'anglais le français non celle arménien
et et puis j'avais appris le lundi à
quel moment
quand je suis venu au canada je vais
vous viennent deux ans maintenant et le
français le français j'avais appris un
peu plus tôt en arménie il avait triché
oui mais il avait bien fait mais mais je
ne sais pas pourquoi le l'anglais a
devancé les jeunes je fais mes études
dans l'anglais après ça mais même si en
arrivant au canada
je parlais français pas d'anglais je ne
sais pas pourquoi c'est la même chose
qui mêle inverse mois en argentine j'ai
eu de l'anglais partout dans ma vie je
faisais mes cours d'anglais à l'école je
faisais des cours d'anglais extra mon
parent il voulait que je parle anglais
j'ai commencé les démarches quand
j'arrive au canada j'apprends le
français puis l'anglais c'est parti
celui qui vient de s'exprimer c'est léo
gimeno de la section l'action américaine
un de nous deux webmestre l'autre
bonjour bonjour l'autre webmestre c'est
marie claude simard et se prenait sort
elles rendent ce parce qu'elle tente de
contacter notre invité mystère
aujourd'hui oui qui est qui est liée au
thème de l'émission aujourd'hui d'en
développer ensemble alors vous
connaissez le jeu c'est le jeu de la
vidéo des cinq images et les vins ne
sais pas mais vous devons vous montrer
quelque chose ya cinq images une vidéo
rapide
vous devez décrire ce que vous voyez
parce que évidemment nous on est à la
radio donc faut décrire deviner la tête
alors vous devinez en cinq images si
vous devenez pas tant pis vous aurez la
réponse au bout de la vidéo vous êtes
prêts oui alors toute la planète jouent
aux jeux vidéo
cinq images on est prêt c'est sans son
20 mois
on vous attend cinq manches la voici
ça c'est gratuit c'est l'image 02 air
canada l avions beau logo ça coûte cher
j'en suis sûr qu'ils aient cette heure
de jeu c'est l'ancien chef tu pourquoi
le candidat de chefferie du parti
conservateur
ouais un homme politique ça c'est un
ancien quart ben qu'est ce qui a causé
image en commun pages d'un journal
important dans l'ouest et qui ce qui est
cette belle femme voyons à montréal tout
le monde la connaît qu'est ce que fait
mélanie joly alors ministre de ses
marques et on parle du français de
l'anglais on peut rien vous cacher les
deux langues officielles du canada
et oui parce que c'était pas cette année
mais l'an prochain on va souligner un
anniversaire important je veux vous le
savez je pas besoin de faire de cours là
dessus l'anniversaire de la création de
la loi sur les langues officielles qui
dit qu'au canada lorsqu'il et on offre
des services en au citoyen oui du côté
canadien fédéral il faut que cela soit
fait dans les deux langues
on célèbre un anniversaire n'est ce pas
et ouais quel âge on vous voit plus plus
plus jeunes que nous touche je sais
c'est sur cinq ans d'accord quand
écouter avant d'aller vers notre invité
spécial c'est le jeu de la peau là bas
c'est la première boule de l'émission
levels il commença dans 98 des années 80
alors il ya trois jeu de la boule la
grosse boule à l'émission chaque jeu on
augmente la mise donc vous allez
chercher des points à quai et vous
remporté le grand prix on le sait saleh
avait de l'argent ou des fois des fois
ça bien que du sûr que dell avait déjà
gagné en livre oui oui des sirops
d'érable
je m'étais quand je viens jamais
alors voilà premières boules c'est pour
essayer de mettre la table pour mieux
comprendre le contexte linguistique
canadien d'accord alors voici la
question est très simple on retrouve au
québec ont représenté la vidéo numéro 2
où se trouve cette question moi je
voudrais pas trop parler parce que je
m'exprime bien dans une des langues
officielles mais quand même les balles
d'alzen je vais viser la mission là de
la grosse boule aujourd'hui on retrouve
au québec quel pourcentage de toute la
population bilingue canadien ça vient
avec un multiples choix justement il n'y
a pas de choix c'est à dire que au
québec il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
bilingues
oui dans d'autres provinces et dévoué et
très peu de gens voilà pour nous on veut
savoir au québec et pourcentage de toute
la population canadienne qui inquiète
bil'in qui vient du québec
sur l'ensemble de la population et
quelques de québécois ouais là dessus on
a peut-être 45% qui sont bilingues être
meilleur sur lens l'as millions ça fait
combien ça s est pas bonne en maths sont
bilingues qui vient du québec
oui selon vous d'accord vous vous dites
combien
18 % 18 pour sa saveur la castille
pourcentage bilingue canadienne de toute
la population bilingue ken de tous les
canadiens qui sont au pays
quel pourcentage moi je dirais 40% et oh
oui je jouais proche d'elle quelques
jours 44 pour ça alors écoutez moi je
suis pas mal fier du 44 pour ça je vous
allez décider qui est la bonne réponse
la province du québec fournit 57% de
toute la population bilingue canadienne
3 millions de citoyens qui sont
bilingues au québec et en ontario ces 23
% de contribuer pour 23% tous les
citoyens ils sont très nombreux près de
14 millions là bas plus qu'au québec en
population totale donc ça vous surprend
vous reste un peu sur notre faim
oui oui je suis vraiment alors très
surprise et on gagne vous savez ces 20
points je pense être offerts
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas pour l'invité
spécial a lancé on va se demander si
l'invité spécial est prêt pour nous tout
est prête et birth est parfaite c'est
fantastique
alors monsieur raymond tu es là et c'est
le nouveau commissaire aux langues
officielles du canada qui est entrée en
vigueur en service le 29 janvier 2018
bonjour commissaire bonjour est ce que
c'est votre première manifestation sur
skype première entrevue son skype oui
c'est ma première manifestation vie
privée vous avez vous déjà tenté
d'utiliser skype pour parler avec un ami
ou une amie oui mais c'est bien ça c'est
charmant
écoutez on veut connaître un peu votre
histoire personnelle passe quand on
devient commissaire ce bien sûr quelque
chose de très officiel qui sera très
important mais ce qu'on apporte au
travail ses antécédents dans votre cas
c'est très précieux pour l'ensemble
la francophonie qui serait aller coûte
présentement vous venez d'un coin dont
on parle pas souvent au canada un
traitement on dirait notre coin l'ordre
mais il s'en passe des choses et il est
facilement je suis originaire du
manitoba un tout petit village qui
s'appelle un an des chaînes hbo lorsque
j'étais enfin tout le monde parlait
français et à l'époque on s'appelait des
canadiens français et donc c'est dans l
hexagone n en existe de mon argent parce
que depuis ce temps la jgt cana des
français j'ai été sans cours de rien
franco manitobain fait partie de
l'acadie mais maintenant qu'un encore
beaucoup de francophones donc une
évolution niveau de l'identité est pour
moi ce qui est important c'est un de mes
objectifs ici c'est d'assurer et de
travailler pour la suite la vitalité de
communauté minoritaire au canada et mon
expérience mon véhicule
c'est ça que j'ai fait partie de
pénalités et de plusieurs mines alité
j'ai aussi comme cherche un beaucoup
utilisé de développement nous communauté
gégé et des gestes et donc ce que jamais
même c'est un vécu passé dans le monde
les minorités dans le ciel bon écoute et
on voit alors on va détailler la faire
au cours de notre conversation j'en suis
certaine loi fédérale annonce un gros
plan de réinvestissement de la
francophonie d'un bilinguisme tant
francophones qu'anglophones au pays
c'était il ya quelques semaines à peine
mais de le savoir à ce qu'ils avaient
déjà fait partie de l'opposition des
gens qui se plaignait du manque
d'investissements du grand canadien dans
sa propre politique officielle de
bilinguisme et bien oui j'ai dans ma
carrière et souvent pleinement des
investissements de la part aussi de
l'apport de main provinciaux j'ai
commencé ma ma carrière comme militant
au mac do bad on pourra dès ce moment là
c'était une question de pousser le
gouvernement
reconnaît la communauté et deuxièmement
d'investir dans cette communauté pour
assurer sa viabilité sa pérennité et
aujourd'hui c'est toujours un débat même
si un plan d'investissement à ce moment
ici c'est toujours une question est-ce
qu'on a les moyens pour répondre à nos
ambitions
écoutez vous connaissez pas le règlement
il y en a pas finalement mais nos amis
et ce autour de la table ils peuvent
aussi poser des questions c'est ce
qu'ils vont faire
mais avant tout parce qu'on n'y arrive à
ce plan d'investissement j'aimerais
donner des réactions à partir d'un
reportage de radio canada qui tout
récent des dyades d'à peine quelques
semaines lorsque l'annoncé a été faite
d'un investissement total de 2,7
j'espère que j'exagère par mois du
tournage ça exagéré non c'est ça ou
alors on regarde la vidéo ensemble en
écoute et après ça on se reparle
et voilà il ya eu donc ça c'est des gens
très négatif
on va écouter la numéro 3 le plus
positif sadi numéro 3 régnant
c'est celle là qu'est ce que ça a coûté
je vous ai aidés parce qu'évidemment mes
instructions sont pas là on se sait
d'asnières sur ses jolies comme nom
parfait donc sa 500 là
le plan d'action repose sur trois
piliers renforcer nos communautés
améliorer l'accès aux services et
promouvoir un canada bilingue dans le
demi milliard de dollars sur cinq ans
promis dans les deux derniers budgets 70
millions iront au financement des
organismes communautaires 63 millions au
recrutement d'enseignants 20 millions au
développement de la petite enfance et 40
millions de dollars à l'immigration
francophone hors québec pour faire
passer le taux à plus de 4 % par année
est ce que le canard mais on doit être
suffisant
c'est avant malgré certains bémols les
organismes qui défendent le français
l'extérieur du québec se sont réjouis de
l'annonce ça fait tellement longtemps
qu'on n'a pas eu d'investissements de
nouveaux investissements à part les
programmes pour les communautés que oui
je considère ce historique c'est la plus
grande action de d'argent dans les
langues officielles qu'on n'ait jamais
eu dans l'histoire du canada donc pour
nous on voit ça d'un est très possible
je pense que il faut qu'on se réjouisse
comme francophones de toute mesure qui
risque d'accroître le statut du français
en alberta il ya du rattrapage à ces
questions là je pense que ça va
permettre aux organisations déstabiliser
appel aux opérations alors monsieur
raymond théberge vous avez reconnu leurs
compagnons d'armes
j'ai pas entendu c'était très positif
c'était très positif c'est rare qu'on
voit seul et à le gouvernement présente
quelque chose de tout le monde dit waouh
le premier intervenant quand même se
demander si 40 millions ce serait
suffisant pour ne pas lui c'est quand
même un bon départ avez vous des
questions pour le commissaire
mais c'est beaucoup d'argent d'investis
ce qui est intéressante ce qui serait
intéressant de savoir c'est comment
est-ce que ça va s'étaler sur combien
d'années pour que ça vaille vraiment la
peine est ce qu'il ne sait ce que vous
le savez oui effectivement le plan
d'action c'est 2,5 et le plan d'action
implique une douzaine de ministères
fédéraux dont il ya plusieurs joueurs il
ya plusieurs intervenants pour la mise
en oeuvre de ce plan d'action parce que
ça touche plusieurs plusieurs champs
d'activités de dans la société soit
l'éducation l'immigration les ors des
médias et c'est donc la clé rhône à
succès pour ce genre de plan d'action
s'était dit assuré que quelqu'un ou un
organisme des questions fédérales en
soit responsable parce que lorsqu'on a
douzaine de ministères
avec dj ses interventions il s'éprend de
quoi redonner une sorte et nous ce qu'on
vaut 20 heures au commissariat ce qu'on
voit sur une veille de la mise en oeuvre
du plan d'action pour s'assurer que les
argents que lille se sont bien investis
court n est pas sur les communautés
j'ai une question pour les immigrants
francophones est ce qu'il ya des
programmes et l'argent prévu pour aider
les immigrants qui viennent des pays
francophones de garder le français de le
promouvoir et de le passer aux enfants
de ces immigrants qui souvent respectée
bec messe dans les provinces anglophones
tout est fait d'un seul homme d'action
il ya un budget spécial pour immigrer au
canada
un budget de 40 millions $ et au sein du
ministère de l'immigration on a créé ce
que tailleur pour l'immigration
francophone et pour assurer qu'au niveau
des autres provinces à l'exception du
québec parce qu'il y en a fixé le style
de 4,4 pour cent que tous les immigrés
doivent être de langue française
l'expression française qui vont
s'installer à l'extérieur du québec et
dans chacune des provinces
effectivement les organismes
responsables pour accueillir ces
immigrés les aider à s'intégrer et la
faire connaître les communautés parce
qu'à l'extérieur du québec dans toutes
les provinces du guizhou par exemple
d'écoles francophones
il ya beaucoup de ressources
francophones donc oui il ya des 15 en
place pour pour aiguiller ces migrants
voilà une question concernant le statut
politique du bilinguisme au canada parce
qu'on on dit souvent que les langues
officielles du canada c'est l'anglais le
français n'est ce pas par contre chaque
province sa langue officielle je pense
que c'est juste un nouveau point de vue
qui officiellement bilingue et puis la
même tv
qui décrète qui sont une ville
francophone ville agglo phone ville
bilingue alors c'est qui qui qui
finalement quitté gouverne tout ça au
niveau du bilinguisme au canada et il
faut s'entendre de la doua cédant
officielle au niveau du lourd du fédéral
et cette loi touche toutes les éditions
paix à tout l'appareil fédéral et régis
assujettis par la loi c'est officiel
mais vous savez très bien que le canada
d'une fédération et que vous ne cliquent
chaque province a très souvent leurs
propres policiers des foyers n'ont pas
nouveau project par exemple est la seule
province officiellement bilingue
nous avons des villes qui sont observés
comme ottawa maintenant la vie david
menton avait deux tiers mais au mieux la
loi s'applique uniquement aux
institutions fédérales
et puis par contre je dis beaucoup
démolition dans les airs en état les
dernières années dans les provinces mais
non le tourne presque toutes les
provinces les solitario des affaires
francophones la fraude
ils ont tous des mines et des affaires
francophones il ya une conférence dvd
affaires francophones et le nom de
service est disponible en français est
ce qu'il ya un problème et moi je me
rappelle dans les années 90 quand
j'étais dans l'ouest canadien jeunes
journalisme me souviens qu'il y avait
une situation aux gones au fédéral
donnait de l'argent dans le cadre du
programme du bilinguisme aux provinces
dans l'administration des cours en
français d'écoles françaises et les
pauvres francophones dans l'ouest
canadien recevait pas au bout de ligne
l'argent était détournée ailleurs dans
le coffre fort du ministre de
l'éducation là bas est-ce qu'il ya
encore des situations comme ça les
communautés reçoivent tel maintenant
directement toutes les sommes d'argent
qui sont annoncées et sans que la
situation s'est nettement améliorée
depuis ce temps là effectivement les
âges c'est quand même des demandes des
communautés
les meilleurs reddition des comptes
savoir que j'ai devancé les agents se
rendent là où sont recensés ce qui est
clair c'est que les investissements en
éducation
on le voit dans les nouvelles écoles on
ne voit dans au niveau de la peau via
niveau professeurs on voit que ce n'est
pas mais je pense que le gros canada on
doit se doter de meilleurs mécanismes de
reddition des gants d'abord ses
investissements en terminant c'est en
fait ce qui a été l'impulsion qui nous a
amenés vers vous cette semaine
il ya déjà trois semaines on s'est dit
il faut parler aux commissaires vous
avez lancé un projet de consultation
avec le public dans le cadre du 60e
anniversaire l'an prochain et des gens
est ce qu'on peut déjà remplir des
questionnaires vous donnez votre opinion
absolument c'est une question
allez une valise le site web du
commissariat où ils disent au
questionnaire ça prend pas beaucoup de
temps
on y voit une réponse agathe d'abord des
canadiens le sondage est en ligne
jusqu'au 31 mai et puis c'est clair
qu'un consensus qui se dégage que c'est
le temps effectivement deux mois dernier
la loi d' apporter certains changements
parce que 1969 et 2006 deux lots sont
passés bon bah écoutez c'est un lien
très très naturel qu'on va pouvoir faire
maintenant vers ceux qui critiquent
enfin vous laisser quitter fils et
châtiment ce fut très agréable de vous
parler et fanta c'est que ce baptême de
l'air je voulais savoir quand on va
connaître les résultats de votre
consultation à ce que ça va se faire
devant le parlement où ce sera publié et
de diverses façons première main et la
consultation une des pistes wave à la
consultation ces deux intervenants et à
l'automne on va déposer position
officielle d'abord monsieur le
commissaire ce fut un plaisir d'avoir ce
premier contact avec vous et puis à
bientôt
merci alors c'était le comice nouveau
commissaire raymond théberge
aux langues officielles du canada la
prochaine fois qu'il va venir on va le
critiquer c'est promis si nécessaire
jean va on va aller vers la critique
d'accord parce qu'elle est présente sur
plusieurs lèvres au canada c'est un
programme fédéral tentaculaire me de
milliardaires maintenant et bien sûr il
ya des gens qui existent mais cinquante
ans plus tard
qu'est ce que ça a changé et est ce
qu'on va être encore avec ce boulet
rouge qu'on va traîner ce boulet dans 50
ans et où est ce qu'il sera plus petit
au plus gros parce que c'est ça quand
même ça coûte des sous on a vu alors
sans faire de commentaire éditorial
maintenant je fonds propres os je fais
un bon on va regarder cette plus de
vidéos qu'on aurait dû regarder plutôt
au moment des conservateurs on l'a vu
avec les rapports du commissaire aux
langues officielles à chaque année une
sorte de laisser aller dans le français
dans la fonction publique et
l'augmentation du bilinguisme est un
enjeu notamment sur laquelle devait se
pencher la première feuille de route on
avait de très grandes ambitions et
peut-être que les objectifs étaient
parés à l'esa l'époque on pensait
pouvoir francisé tous les jeunes
anglophones le fait que le bilinguisme
ne verrait devait être au coeur des
institutions politiques canadiens on
devait offrir aux citoyens des services
dans les deux langues s'étaient aussi
les grandes périodes des débats
constitutionnels des conflits
linguistiques
or aujourd'hui ce qu'on compte ce qu'ont
constaté que la question linguistique ne
structure pu plus du tout le débat
public canadien
quand on regarde par exemple les grandes
institutions les nationales
linguistiquement divisée comme l'office
national du film par exemple radio
canada ce sont des institutions qui
pardonnez-moi s'essouffle un peu du
moins dans les dernières dans les
dernières années on a coupé beaucoup de
financement de ces institutions là quand
on voit la manière dont par exemple
justin trudeau le premier ministre
traite la question linguistique la
dualité linguistique avec un peu de
désinvolture peut voir finalement clair
que cette question la question de la
dualité finalement les plus une
composante essentielle de l'identité
canadienne quoi qu'en dise quoi que
peuvent en dire justement les sondages
des sondages qu'on a vu récemment
alors quoi qu'il peut en dire évidemment
on s'essouffle policière à du canada
c'est certain bon écoute et on est prêt
pour le jeu de la deuxième grosse boule
c'est très simple c'est là chaque
semaine on simplifie le site web du feu
c'est maintenant la deuxième boule de
l'émission la deuxième on avait un en
troisième position cela vous pour
combien de points va demander à l'eva
japon combien de points et de nous lire
la question bien sûr ses 30 points 30
points qu'elle est un des trois mots
qu'ils utilisent les canadiens pour
décrire le fait que leur pays
officiellement bilingue lépi qui revient
le plus souvent pour des cons utilise au
canada pour décrire ce programme de
langues officielles là je comprends pas
mais la question bain par exemple c'est
une belle boule belle serait un des mots
qu'on pourrait utiliser le plus
fréquemment pour décrire cette boule
ok alors qu'elle est et trois mots on
utilise de plus fréquemment pour des co
écrire ce beau programme
est-ce qu'on est permis de dire ça à la
radio on a dit des mots vraiment ces
dernières non mais la semaine dernière
parlé de prononcer des mots plus
controversé non mais je suis pas contre
eux vincent cacchione au sujet du
ministre non moi je l' ai dit trois fois
de suite lorsqu'il s'est pas une des
bonnes réponses vous avez droit à un
deuxième choix non mais vous avez droit
deuxième choc du monde bien sûr qu est
qu est ce qu est ce qu ils pouvaient
être utopique je vais dire utopique très
bien utopique
moi j'ai une proposition est donc
inutile quand inutile ça n'en fait pas
votre opinion personnelle mais l'opinion
des canadiens d'accord et vous les eaux
j'ai aucune baisse je sait pas aucune
idée très bien très bon choix alors vous
me dire qui d'après vous entre utopique
inutile
aucune idée et cher a remporté la bonne
réponse de ceux de ce deuxième grosse
boule parce que voici les trois réponses
qui viennent le plus souvent des mots
fierté à vous via rien dans ce que vous
avez des inquiétudes
ça commence à se rapprocher d'eux mais
pas tout à fait et indifférence on y
arrive on est très proche de inutile 30
points c'est vrai la de ses fiertés est
inquiétudes indifférent le feeling c'est
on veut des nations par rapport à ça
bien sûr et puis c'est un rapport fait
par un organisme canadien c'est très
sérieux cet effet par le gouvernement
qui a voulu savoir ce qu'on en pense et
ce sont les plus fiers qu'ils en sont
les plus fiers je pense mais canadiens
français où les canadiens anglais il
faudrait demander au ministère canadien
du patrimoine d'accord ce sera pour la
prochaine
alors voilà donc on à 20.30 points il
reste un dernier jeu qui va surgir plus
tard à l'émission j'aimerais vous
proposer la question tam-tam qu'on a
affiché sur vous savez comment
fonctionne à l'émission non non
alliant que la voici la question tam-tam
semaine on va sur facebook
déposez un oeuf
[Musique]
stéphane pont dès que marie-claude met
en images
voilà vous dites c'est comme c'est comme
pas et on s'est un petit peu est de
savoir et on est des fois comme on dit
en acb et s'étoffe de savoir les
l'opinion des canadiens c'est pas facile
on n'a pas beaucoup de réactions souvent
mais là il ya eu des réactions
voici ce qu'elle est la question
leonardo voyez-vous d'un bonnet ou non
l'application de la loi canadienne sur
les langues officielles concernant
l'utilisation du français et de
l'anglais dans les services offerts aux
citoyens
réponse de juni garraud qui est au
canada qu est ce qu ils répondent oui
bon c'est bien c'est clair ça coûte pas
cher
serge la marche s'annonce très gentil
c'est sympathique anne-marie vont
qu'est-ce qui est alors que dit serge la
marche je vis en colombie britannique et
les services en français existe mais il
ya de grands bancs manque d'écoles
françaises par exemple
bon on en a parlé un peu et puis milk
garot vous l'avez pas vu sur mais vous
l'avez vu hier
prenons pas ce que je vais voir le
garrot qui habite semble t il y aurait
peut-être un peu hors sujet mais vous
m'expliquer là mais il s'annonce très
intéressant quand même personnellement
j'ai grandi avec le système impérial et
la langue française les pieds les
pousser la verge téléshopping
les cuillères à thé sucre peut souvent
mon sucre soupe leur tasse de quatre ans
les verts à jus de quatre ans
et bonjour bonsoir et merci le temps de
ma jeunesse a beaucoup changé et je ne
peux pas m'habituer aux métriques et
c'est un peu glissé si vous voulez un
peu en dehors de la question
oui mais je pense qu'il était dans la
machine dans le futur et il sait que
dans huit semaines exactement nous
allons à l'émission parlez du système
métrique et du système impérial au
canada je sais pas comment les gens
un voyage de ski bourgat je sais pas
c'est un trait d'esprit ni non les
personnes qui capable de faire ça alors
je sais pas comment ça des fois ça
arrive mais on sait qu'il tente français
oui mais les choses ont beaucoup changé
depuis qu'il est jeune je sais pas s'il
a changé mais ça fait quelques années je
connais des gens qui en voyage et pour
leur pays des asiatiques puisqu'elle se
sont rendus dans des années consulat
puis des ambassades de canadiens puis
avait des gens qui parlaient pas
français
par exemple puis ça c'est une quelque
chose très important et écouter ses
bilingue on est bilingue
on doit l'être en fait on peut on peut
l'être
puis les gens les gouvernements il faut
qu'ils nous offrent les deux langues
mais à ces moments là y'avait pas je ne
sais pas si maintenant c'est corrigé
mais c'est tellement qui est intéressant
de bilinguisme quelqu'un qui fuit et qui
est l'objet d'un vol qui perd son
passeport qui a besoin d'une halle au
consulat et qui se retrouvent qui est
francophone il n'ya que des gens qui
parlaient en anglais vous me décrivez
une situation qui a l'air tout à fait
aberrantes pour nous parce que nous
sommes francophones mais les anglophones
dans font ça change rien à leur vie moi
juste un exemple je vis dans un quartier
très très très anglophone et ce sont des
anglophones qui ne parle pas un mot de
français
c'est au québec et ils ont ils sont nés
là et ils vont mourir là parce que vous
leur parlez bien sûr mais j'en parle en
anglais mois ne peuvent pas me parler en
france mais moi moi j'habite à l'ouest
de l'île de montréal
oui c'est vraiment à l'ouest de pisser
la plupart des anglophones qui m'ont
jugé dangereux par le dépanneur par
exemple plus j'aime en français peut il
me répond en anglais
oui mais je continue à parler en
français puis mais répond y compris et
comprennent mais ils n'osent pas parler
en français je sois pourquoi avec ce qui
serait une bonne méthode ce qui serait
une bonne méthode je te parle dans ma
langue tu me réponds dans ma langue n a
pas de problème moi je pense que
l'oiseau l'est par exemple avec des
études
plusieurs années mais c'était comme
protamines endroits à montréal où
peut-être au québec où des gens était le
plus utile surtout les jeunes parce que
maintenant mais paraît que ça bouge je
les connais des coins où il ya des
panneaux qui disent stop seulement
oui il parait parler d'eux je pense
qu'il ya des villes parce que peut-il
fonctionner sur le réseau lille qui sont
leurs langues officielles encore si je
me trompe pas c'est encore mais vous
quand vous êtes arrivé au canada c'est
bien vu qu'il y avait deux là que à part
le russe et l'armagnac est ce que vous
avez été à peu perdu dans le système ça
vous est pris un petit bout de temps à
comprendre comment ça fonctionne et ici
est ce que les choses avaient l'air
logique ou artificielle ce que je
trouvais vraiment drôle c'est ce que m a
rien de la parole qu'il y avait des gens
qui ont vécu ici toute leur vie elle ne
parlait pas
le clan soit l'anglais ou le français
parce que moi j'avais l'autre un autre
expérience car par exemple ma femme qui
parle anglais ou à l'époque ne parlait
pas de français on s'est trouvés se
trouvait dans l'est de montréal
elle était perdue il n'y avait personne
qui parlait anglais qui pouvait
expliquer comment se rendre à la
prochaine station de métro alors c'est
une réalité qui existe deux côtés aussi
et pour nous en étant des immigrants ont
réalisé très vite que pour avancer dans
notre vie dans notre carrière il fallait
parler les deux c'est sûr que c'est très
difficile de maîtriser les deux langues
en même temps et un moment donné
dépendamment de où tu commences
travailler si c'est un milieu
francophone ou être un milieu anglophone
une des deux langues prend l'avancé
mais on a bien compris qu'il fallait
parler du en venant de pays moi je suis
grande y alex l'union soviétique où
j'étais né en arménie j'ai parlé à ma
langue army maternelle c'est l'arménie
mais la lingua franca les langues
officielles de l'union soviétique était
le russe alors chaque république avait
sa langue nationale sa langue officielle
mais tout le monde aussi apprenait le
russe et j'imagine écoutez moi mes
parents par exemple et et ils ont allé
dans une école russe ils m'ont envoyé
dans une école russe personne n'a forcé
c'était juste heureux connaissance que
pour avancer dans la vie il fallait
comprendre et parler juste et bien
un peu plus tôt on parlait des québécois
qui ce qui représente leur progression
de tous les canadiens qui sont bilingues
mais ce n'est tout de même moins de 50 %
des québécois qui sont bilal est encore
sam chicotte encore j'aimerais bien
savoir c'est quoi leur bilinguisme lâche
ça m'étonne tellement à montréal où il
ya beaucoup de gens qui se disent
bilingue mais
est-ce qu'ils parlent vraiment l'anglais
ou le français
moi je suis là je parle l'espagnol lui
les mêmes sources casion méritoire
c'est que j'ai vécue comme que mimi
glargine et l'argentine je parle
espagnol est à la maternelle
j'appris les français quand je suis
arrivé ici mais je note une différence
très important quand je parle là des
francophones et parfois c'est pas tout
le temps mais il ya des fois que je
parle de faire des francophones et de
francophiles marca com sinon s'il ne
comprend pas mais du côté anglais moi je
parle un anglais entre guillemets pourri
et les gens y et s'est demandé qui
essaye de comprendre qui ils corrigent
pas trop pire mais du côté français
c'est beaucoup plus il faut il faut être
bien dans la langue
puis je me rappelle toujours un phrase
de ma femme qui est prêt et a reçu un
prix et quand il a commencé les gens
d'ici qui parlaient français drôle
maintenant elle parle
voyez comme c'est toujours cette
histoire décès bien acceptée si je parle
très bien si je parle pas bien si les
gens aiment airgas de jean aimé qu'on
prend c'est embêtant tous ces choix là
même pour le premier ministre trudeau
je pense ou ce médecin au mois de
janvier dernier celui-là mais en 2017
elle a causé beaucoup de remous il était
au québec dans la ville de sherbrooke je
me souviens bien
puis à une anglaise une madame anglaise
qui était dans un forum public organisé
par monsieur trudeau que faisait le tour
du pays comme ça et elle a eu à poser
une question en anglais
la pauvre dame à comprenait pas le
français qu'est ce qu'a fait le premier
ministre du canada
le champion du bilinguisme 1 parce qu'en
france on va regarder un va croquer
cette scène de l'éducation la dame qui
lui avait posé la question à la peau est
en mesure de comprendre la réponse
monsieur trudeau a révisé sa position
est admis que peut-être
il aurait dû combiner les deux langues
officielles écouter ce qu'ils répondent
effectivement j'aurais peut-être
peut-être pu répondre en partie en
anglais en partie en français et sur
réflexion serait s'arrêter une une bonne
chose à faire mais moi ma préoccupation
c'est toujours de prendre autant de
questions que possible et je suis très
conscient que au au québec
c est la langue de molière qui prend le
dessus alors pour utiliser un anglicisme
me prendre le plus de questions
possibles
je pense qu'on devrait conseiller de
prendre des questions en anglais c'est
plus rapide en anglais en français et on
s'est éternisé
j'avais une petite anecdote pour vous
j'ai enseigné justin trudeau
non oui parce que toute la famille
trudeau en fait à ottawa
à l'époque où leur père était le premier
ministre et moi j'étais étudiante à
l'université il y avait un programme de
moniteurs de langue seconde
donc nous les étudiants on était payé
c'était notre emploi on aller dans les
écoles à ottawa pour enseigner le
français aux jeunes enfants
donc il était à l'école primaire et
j'avais tant d'heures a donné par
semaine je me suis retrouvé dans leur
école
donc voilà j'ai essayé de lui enseigner
quelques bonne base de français je sais
pas si 550 $ de plus en dessous de la
table mais bien sûr que non mais toute
façon c'était pas seulement pour eux
c'était pour toute la classe
ils allaient dans une école d'immersion
française
donc ce n'était pas sa première langue
ah mais non parce qu'avec maman ça se
passait surtout en oui d'accord mais
papa était occupé à autre chose qu'à
écouter une histoire de famille on
racontera cette histoire un jour j'en
suis certain chronique polio pour écrire
un livre ou deux là dessus et ce n'est
pas le propos aujourd'hui troisième
bulls initiants accord de prêt on a
trois boules à cette émission c'est
incroyable trois d'habitude
alors voici la troisième bull alors on
va demander à marie claude exprimé
troisième bol pour 50 points sur 100
jeunes anglophones canadiens combien
parle les deux langues officielles
il habite où on exclut justin trudeau
médecin au dessus j'habite au québec ou
à l'extérieur du québec je sens jeunes
anglophones au canada
ça qu'avec lui les anglophones au québec
than 3 mais j'exagère encore 9 7 a coûté
ses 23 août 12 d'accord n 7
marie claude baland 12,7 kays très
adapté j'ai une nouvelle pour vous je
trouvais alors je veux donner à
préambule avant la répondre j'adore
prendre mon temps moi que je francophone
préambule et les jeunes francophones au
canada sont de plus en plus nombreux à
parler le français et l'anglais en 71
déjà 39 % des jeunes francophones de 15
à 24 ans et toby la francofête
il n'était plus de 55 % en 2011 jours
maintenant sur 100 jeunes anglophones
canadiens
voici la situation chez eux si un petit
peu différent des cadets les
francophones moins de 10% étaient
bilingues en 71 40 ans plus tard à peine
un peu plus de 13% d'entre eux parlent
lé dollar
4 c'est 70% aujourd'hui on applaudit
mais en même temps c'est un peu normal
et quelles sont les raisons pour eux
d'apprendre le français si tu habites à
vancouver où si tu habites à ical oui
tout si tu habites pourquoi t'apprendrai
le français moi je prendrais l'espagnol
j'ai essayé de m'entraîner chez nous
j'ai une question alors on parle anglais
français mais pourquoi dengue autochtone
noyarey pas des langues autochtones
officielle au canada dire si les vannes
très bonne question
oui d'ailleurs ça était proposée par
roméo saganash mans mais combien
lesquels qui on va mettre comme il aime
comme quelque chose qu'on 120 langues
officielles si ça fait des milliards
c'est sûr que au canada on a des langues
autochtones qui ont moins de 500 gens
qu'ils les langues c'est l'anglais les
français depuis les langues autochtones
soient des langues officielles moi
j'allais voter je pas être politiquement
incorrect mais j'allais voter pour
l'espagnol comme aux etats-unis c'est la
deuxième fille ciellement mais
officieusement nommer toutes les
panneaux partout aux états-unis sont
bilingues l'espagnol vous êtes la plus
grande communauté linguistique en dehors
des francophones et anglophones au
canada
dépendant des pros c'était pas comme ça
il ya 30 ans non ne nous est une force à
intervenir ils sont déjà
oui alors je me promenais avec ma
famille pour le centre-ville md montréal
puis je trouver un couple un jeune
couple qui était vraiment il sait parler
en espagnol vidéo ici à passion qui
parlent espagnol plus je me tourne mais
je déboule espagnol dit non mais on n'a
trouvé personne dans les centres ville
de montréal parc du coin très peuplées
moi je dis qu'ils parlent espagnol perd
4,5 alors vous voyez il ya des gens qui
parlent espagnol
il ya beaucoup de gens qui parlent
espagnol sortie chaque sac la semaine
prochaine on parler chinois l'émission
loup le mandarin faudrait quand même
utiliser l'humour dans le bon contexte
un spa on va donner un cours la semaine
prochaine qui est probablement la langue
la plus utilisée au canada après le
relais français pour l'arabie ça sent
bien aussi un petit mois j'aimerais ça
on va tirer l'affairé au clair c est ce
que c'est l'arabe est ce que c'est le
chinois est ce que c'est l'espagnol en a
des chiffres ferme là dessus la semaine
prochaine d'accords ce qu'ils ont été
mis à jour ce sont les langues de radio
canada international découvrira qu'à
découvrir le canada a mis à jour et les
statistiques linguistique c'est la
première page qui sautent au visage
quand on clique sur découvrir le canada
c'est pas compliqué tu ne s'apprend pas
2 3 avec moi je me remets découvrir le
canada c'est un chino dan son ordinateur
puis ça va ça c'est un carte du canada
puis on peut voir tout les démontrer
tout de suite si vous le faites ils
iront pas avoir eux-mêmes nous
intervenons mais on va canada
c'est une des onglets en haut il la
salle
car voilà alors ces langues officielles
anglais français ok des réponses aux
questions avant même qu'elle soit posée
les cinq langues les plus parlées dans
les foyers anglais français mandat ray
lane est lé chabiba donc la troisième
langue ciel devrait être le mandarin
ouais d'accord ça va tu cela prend juste
répondu abe l'arménien est il sur la
liste
messieurs mais le sommet de la
francophonie serait à yerevan cette
année au mois d'octobre
j'espère de voir sur la planète mars
aucune culture se trouve dans quel pays
lee erevan la capitale de l'arménie faut
tous apprendre quelque chose aujourd'hui
dans cet important
ainsi c'est fantastique alors vous allez
voir tout les pays francophones
1 les vans evans il va falloir vous
réinviter merci beaucoup avec plaisir à
les apporter une perspective bien
différente du reste de l'équipe
merci beaucoup là bas merci beaucoup
pour l'invitation
anne-marie vont toujours un plaisir de
vous avoir parmi nous à bientôt
et puis marie claude simard bonne
semaine de vacances une semaine de
vacances je reviens donc prêt dans deux
semaines donc il va falloir travailler
bouchées doubles la semaine prochaine je
vais fait le loft pouces oui alors on va
faire quelque chose qu'on fait jamais
puisqu'il nous reste à peu près quatre
minutes à gaspiller amende de perdre le
signal
on va se prendre une caméra à l'autre on
en a quatre ou à les faire jouer
un matin à wil a dit l'auteur en premier
c'est vrai et ensuite on fait comme ça
on s'appesantit pas sur l'animateur ça
dure deux secondes
c'est quoi une journée bonne semaine de
la semaine prochaine la bonne journée
voyons cela
on vous croit me revoilà non et puis
ensuite c'est fini ça finit y'en a pas
une autre là non non non